put on your giant bear coat and spray
yourself down with your best zombie
scented perfume because loot is back
wake up with the perfect sunny-side egg
breakfast shaper or if you're in a hurry
just floss with your breakfast on take
some dessert with you for later and
don't forget to feed the squirrels out
of their own heads with this send out
stamp with your face on them at the
photo stamp store where you can upload
personalized photos and make your very
own stamps and nobody will think that
you're vain at all don't worry about it
but if a gift with your own face on it
isn't enough you can buy your friends
and family a piece of America one square
inch at a time at own a piece of America
comm you can buy people their own land
even a piece of a state for just three
dollars and ninety five cents per square
inch if you need something special for
the lady in your life there's a lot of
science tacular jewelry out there like
this cyanobacteria inspired necklace
these DNA and RNA matching lockets sloth
rings or the scariest necklace of all
time that goes perfect with this hyper
realistic baby mask make your own
personalized jewelry by taking these
pills filled with 24 karat gold leaf
that make you poop glittery gold and for
the ladies with no time to sit down they
make this handy dandy female pee device
alright time to move on if you're hungry
you can cook something up with this
kosher cookbook of imaginary animals
that reveals everything you need to know
about fictional beasts and whether or
not it's kosher to eat them including
centaurs basileus and all of these
mysterious monsters or keep it simple
and just have some sushi doormat better
yet just shoot sushi out of this sushi
bazooka which if eat enough of one of
these placemats would be rated awesome
Lionel Richie break hello is it me
you're cooking for or is it Bri either
way don't forget to season your meal
with sadness courtesy of a jar of salt
made from human tears later the adults
can get saucy with some vodka made from
cow's milk guess what finally twelve
female styrofoam heads are all for sale
at the same place get them now blocking
out sights and sounds from your head is
easy with the hiber mate a luxury eye
mask with removable earmuffs that
totally blocks out life and has been
rated safe for use in environments up to
90 decibels rated H for Harry is the
hairy chest sweater that at least will
match your Harry wookie longboard from
Jeff McCleary of weird boards and if
it's raining you'll be equipped with
your windshield wiper goggles and
submarine umbrella complete with
periscope but remember if it's too hot
your tights will melt off we're almost
done so curl up with your USB leg
warmers pull out your pillow remote go
to sleep sitting upright and as always
thanks for watching